[Música]
como cada 17 de junio hoy se celebra el
día mundial para combatir la
desertificación y la sequía para
concientizar además a la población sobre
la problemática que afecta a todo el
planeta a un ritmo cada vez más
acelerado este año españa fue el país
anfitrión para el acto de inauguración
al que acudió nuestra corresponsal en
madrid de marina a colorado marina la
saludo muy buena tarde ya en madrid le
pregunto cómo está el calor y también
explicarnos un poco qué son las de
certificaciones de certificación mejor
dicho y cómo nos afecta
bueno pues el calor va poco a poco
subsidiando estamos llegando al final de
esta ola de calor en madrid aunque hay
muchas zonas del país que todavía tienen
temperaturas superiores a los 40 grados
así que todavía queda bastante calor por
delante y estamos como bien decíamos
hace unos días ni siquiera hemos
empezado el verano oficialmente así que
nos espera un largo y caluroso verano
aquí en españa como me preguntabas que
significa la desertificación pues es la
degradación paulatina de tierras secas o
semi secas que son naturalmente fértiles
pero que a causa de esta degradación
dejan de ser productivas las causas de
esta degradación de suelos suelen ser no
naturales es decir causadas por agentes
externos en este caso sobre todo por los
humanos como por ejemplo la
sobreexplotación de los suelos la
minería el mal uso del agua del recurso
natural o la deforestación por ejemplo
con incendios causados por los humanos
como hemos visto en la amazonía durante
tantos años y malas prácticas ganaderas
o agrícolas hay que diferenciarlo de la
desertización que es un proceso natural
como por ejemplo pasó con el desierto
del sahara que a lo largo de varias
décadas la tierra fue convirtiéndose en
desierto recordemos desertización es
desertificación es un proceso no natural
y desertización un proceso natural como
nos afecta pues dos terceras partes del
planeta están en proceso de
desertificación un porcentaje que en
españa llega al 74 por ciento del
territorio que está en riesgo de este
proceso en latinoamérica no están
exentos tampoco de este peligro bolivia
chile ecuador y perú están entre un 27%
y un 43 por ciento de su territorio en
riesgo de desertificación
un proceso que en bolivia alcanza el 77
por ciento del territorio así que como
vemos es un proceso un fenómeno no
natural que afecta a todo el mundo que
en que deriva la degradación de estos
suelos pues en escasez de alimentos que
puede derivar
en consecuencia en conflictos civiles
también en hambrunas y migraciones
forzadas como lo hemos visto en varios
lugares del planeta incluidos por
ejemplo en centroamérica 700 millones de
personas están en riesgo de
desplazamiento debido a la sequía y
aunque el continente africano es
históricamente el más afectado por este
fenómeno de falta de agua de la sequía
ya que el 44 por ciento de las últimas
sequías en los últimos 100 años han sido
en este continente como lo recordó la
activista climática keniana que estuvo
aquí en esta presentación hoy patricia
combo todo el planeta es
es post potencial es víctima de la
sequía y de la desertificación y de
nosotros los humanos marina le pregunto
entonces de los detalles de este evento
pues este evento fue en el en el museo
reina sofía de madrid como pueden ver a
mis espaldas ya ha terminado hace varios
minutos están desmontando todo el
escenario donde había varias
personalidades entre ellas el presidente
del gobierno español pedro sánchez
también habló a través de
videoconferencia el secretario general
de las naciones unidas antonio guterres
y el director ejecutivo de la convención
de las naciones unidas contra la
desertificación y la sequía el mauritano
ibrahim dio en el en este evento en el
que hubo ponencias y mesas redondas
y hicieron insistieron en la necesidad
de ponernos de acuerdo de una manera
multisectorial para poner freno a la
sequía puesto que tenemos las
herramientas tenemos la tecnología lo
que pedían era un cambio de mentalidad
para que todos hagamos más para combatir
este fenómeno y sobre todo cambiar el
paradigma de la reacción a convertirnos
en proactivos para poder combatir como
decía este fenómeno
edificación de la sequía durante la
cop15 de la conferencia de las partes
que se celebró en costa de márfil en
mayo de este año sobre desertificación y
sequía llegaron al acuerdo de
de restaurar 1 mil millones de hectáreas
de área degradada veremos si es uno de
esos acuerdos que si se cumple o que se
queda sólo en palabras